right through the city like British
[Music]
through the city like British if you
ain't thick please don't get involved
now London
what's up man we're live I wasn't ready
but when you're live you're live we'll
do it live we'll do it live happy uh
Labor Day everybody
happy labor day I think a lot of people
are what barbecuing on Labor Day really
Memorial Day is the barbecue Day Labor
Day a Monday a little tricky
uh like what's your family do on Labor
Day
I guess you get a little Grill and Grill
the burgers your family do anything NADA
we don't do anything
nah kids are out from school so that's I
mean they're crunk for Labor Day but
outside that we're in here working kids
um fun little weekend not a bad weekend
before jumping this bit I was about to
say big UFC 293 but there's
it's not big it's not big it's a tough
sell I'm not gonna lie to you but uh the
UFC had to put the card together
um we'll get into that there's a variety
of reasons why this car's card is a
little light it's a it's a Diet Coke
card you're not getting that full sugary
Coke Pay-per-view on this you're getting
that Diet Coke pay-per-view and they're
back on Izzy selling this bad boy I
don't think they care too much but we'll
get into it uh weekend was good you had
some fights over the weekend you had UFC
Paris So Gone looked uh good coming off
uh his loss to Jon Jones so he is back
in Action uh a lot of people thought
Sergey would give him more problems than
he did he looked terrible let's just
call it what it is he looked very bad uh
out of his League one dimensional the
takedowns weren't there
um and I don't know if Cyril Gods take
down defense got better if Sergey just
didn't set it up well
um not a great showing for Spivak there
sir again good I don't know where it
puts him because Sergey was ranked what
seven I'll check right now seven eight
you know you lost to Jon Jones uh you
just beat Sergey who was kind of on a
surge there so yeah seven two seven you
got Ty fighting this weekend
yeah I don't know what it really does
for uh surrogon just keeps them in those
top in the top threes number two right
now
um
I bet we get Thomas when I'll zero God
next
that's what Tom called for that's what
we get next and I bet you we get it
before the end of the year because
cereal God didn't even get hit there
barely broke a sweat Tom looked
phenomenal in his fight
um and they want him to be the next
thing yeah yeah so you do Tom or sir
gone in December
big December card that'd be cool I think
Tom beats the brakes out of him but
that's nor here you know there fry fro
and Rose
um
29 28 I guess uh Rose looked pretty
undersized in that fight she doesn't
seem to put it together I think a lot of
the punches that Pharrell was throwing
Rose was rolling with it but it looked
bad in the judge's eyes but Rose just
never had much success in the fight
didn't look great didn't look like he
wanted to be there for Rose it's always
a mental thing so that's two losses in a
row
see what she does
see what she does uh ozma look good not
a great card let's call what it is not a
great card this pay-per-view this
Saturday I think even though it's not a
casuals gangbusters pay-per-view that
people can come out and barbecue and get
their friends around the the tube and
watch
um this card is gonna be pretty exciting
so I think that's gonna sell itself but
again it's not gonna do gangbusters
numbers I'll tell you what's doing
gangbuster numbers when I see you Buffs
if you're cause football fam I see Buffs
are back with vengeance uh they beat TCU
now they looked phenomenal they answered
a lot of questions I think uh Dion has
something like 83 or 85 new players on
the roster there's usually 112 on the
roster he had 85 new players so we knew
they were stacked with Talent
um but you just don't know how it's
gonna look on the field the coaching are
they disciplined first game a bunch of
five star recruits four star recruits
three star recruits are they gonna be
disciplined are they gonna play as a
team and damn they look good they look
good defense a little suspect now here's
the question is tcu's offense that good
and you know and it's gonna they're
gonna be hanging you know 35 40 points
on everybody the rest of the season or
do does the the sea buff defense need to
get back to the drawing board get back
on that practice field and and kind of
seal up that defense that's the question
I don't think we'll find out about
Nebraska and not worry about Nebraska uh
CSU going to completely Molly [__] as
usual uh then they play Oregon a lot of
questions will be answered in that
Oregon game they will go into that
Oregon game undefeated
um they have Oregon and then they have
USC you can get your answers there
Nebraska a good team Will Compton you
know this and if you want to bet
whatever you want to do Bud uh Nebraska
the best team to figure out a way to
lose all games lately
um last season this season so the best
you know team who just can't win but I
think they're gonna have their hands
full with CU especially now that the
cat's out of the bag and the quarterback
Deion Sanders son listen I had my doubts
he's from HBCU
that's a completely different level than
the the Pac-12 and this big boy college
football complete you can talk about
nine day difference but he looked like a
freaking surgeon out there threw for 500
yards CU record think he beat up my boy
Joel klatt's record against CSU which
was uh previously at 400 something yards
um and then Travis Hunter and this kid
you got Sanders that quarterback you got
Travis Hunter at wide receiver
cornerback he's been hopefuls what's up
holler CU buff football is popping I'm
so excited man we we won one game last
year one game dog now turn on ESPN turn
on Fox it's all anybody talks about we
won one game last year that's the power
of Deion Sanders now don't get wrong
Dion brings the kids in but the the
positive to me was how disciplined they
were not a lot of penalties discipline
team you know not Travis Hunter
he reminds me of Charles if you remember
this back in college football days you
might know that Charles Woodson vibe
that that you know when Charles Woodson
would play receiver and corner he would
do a million plays was the main focus on
the field he's that but great for this
hot take he's better receiver than
Charles Woodson was and now is he just
as good as a corner but my god did he
look good he has some work to do I know
it's early but he has some work to do
sorry I'm excited about my CU Buffs I'm
excited about I know you guys gave him a
verified dog and I'll get to that but go
Buffs baby we're gonna beat the brakes
off Nebraska enjoy that Will Compton
um so yeah let's uh let's get into this
UFC 293 card in Australia there will be
a live fight companion on Joe Rogan's
YouTube and then we'll right after that
goes live once we're done it will be
uploaded on Spotify that's Joe Rogan
Spotify this is a JRE fight companion
with Brian Callan Sam tripley Eddie
Bravo's in Japan so we Brown the next
best conspiracy theorist so he got Sam
tripley Brian Callan Mr Joseph Rogan and
myself it's going down I think it's uh
is a regular 7 P.M start time
I think so yeah
yeah so regular 7 P.M start time uh
that's Pacific so that would be eight
over there eight right and uh I did this
last time you're from Texas chin right
figure it out it's eight right
the main character eight over there or
is it nine I think it's eight
908 in Texas right now so two hours
ahead no it's a freaking so so it's 908
here
you're so it's two hours ahead so if
it'd be nine uh Main Event time over
there
yeah they're two hours ahead central
time that makes sense so bad boys gonna
start at nine on jre's uh YouTube that
should be fun that's why I'm not too
worried about the card I'm gonna have
fun no matter what I'd watch freaking
kids play freaking paper rock scissors
and do a companion for it and such a
good time so uh but let's get into the
card again the card's not gonna blow
your hair back but you're gonna miss out
if you don't get this pay-per-view
because there are some good matchups on
this card and whenever the general
audience is like I'm gonna pass on those
one it's not a good card they're usually
the best cards it's just the way it goes
for whatever reason
um
or spend the majority of the time on
Izzy and Sean Strickland so last night
and this morning I'm doing my homework
before you guys before we go live for at
9 00 a.m and my mission was to find a
way Sean Strickland gets this done
I would love to hear it
uh from somebody that knows the game how
you see
the easiest path to victory for Sean
Strickland now you will say well if he
grapples is he's you know the one
drinking his arm is the grappling look
what Jan did to him uh-huh that's not
Sean Strickland Sean Strickland fancies
himself a striker and he's a volume
puncher
um
I'm just I'm trying to figure this out
and not to you know there's no hate on
Sean Strickland I like the guys he's one
of my favorite Personalities in the
sport we have him on the show great dude
what he's done you know with his records
insane man insane uh but this is black
and white take out my like for Sean
Strickland take out my love for Izzy
take all that out this is black and
white
if you look at the let's just start with
the strength of schedule as far as the
resumes go
who if if we're if you're arguing for
Sean Strickland right now
who's his best win
what what's the highest caliber guy that
he's beat
Jack Hermanson
by Jack Hermanson or
Uriah Hall that's you you're at Hall two
years ago
he's lost to the the top like he lost
Kamara Usman uh right uh uh let's come
out Usman when he's at 70 and then
obviously he lost to acts uh pierra he
lost to Jared Canon there
um and then the UFC game two random uh
tough nose dudes from the likes of
Russia
uh his best win I would say Jack
Romancing is a good win that's a split
decision by the way
um his best win was probably his last
fight Michael Madoff if you know
magomerov stylistically bad fight for
for Sean Strickland and he got it he
Molly wopped this dude Molly [__] this
dude this dude should have gave him all
the problems
um and he just did it Sean just put it
on him and acts absolutely melted this
dude so that's probably his best win
against the toughest opponent his last
one which is good if you're Sean
Strickland fan but as far as strength of
schedule again to to
correlate just a football this is
strength strength strength of schedule
Sean Strickland's more like uh uh you
know a Florida International and is the
strength of schedule would be like
Alabama Georgia
and he's winning he is winning uh his
two-way it was win over Alex in his last
fight to retain the middleweight
championship belt coming off a loss that
shows you the kind of uh mentality that
Izzy has there obviously beat Jared
Cannon there not a great fight but he
completely dismantled him
um and Strickland lost him but MMA math
doesn't work here uh the Robert
Whittaker fight super impressive vittori
impressive uh obviously the yawn at 205.
again this is this is when I will invest
in a fighter so he's on he's on defeat
he's 20-0 decides to shoot for the moon
at light heavyweight to get to Jon Jones
fights young which is an awful matchup
how dare you so they have him fight Yan
he loses that fight he loses that fight
right has to be embarrassing he's like
God dang it after that he's probably
back to never lost an MMA before lost in
kickboxing but never lost MMA before
comes back and rattles off three
freaking wins
um you know Marvin Victoria stay people
top five Staple in the middleweight
division Robert Whittaker might be the
best guy especially at the time not
named Izzy beats him Jerry can air
Savage monster you should fight at
heavyweight so he dismantles vittori
dismantles Robert Whitaker dismantles
Jared Canon there then he gets Alex
Pierre the boogeyman who's beat him
before right beat him twice before in
kickbox and he loses to him I got this
is it this is what the UFC was doing
Alex appears the exact matchup that's
why they
stream them to the front of the line
there's a fun story there he looks like
a monster they streamline him he beat
Tennessee I think it was actually the
best thing happened in Z Square he beats
Izzy like man what is he gonna do this
guy's bigger he has the same credential
as far as kickboxing goes he's beat him
twice nice 3-0 what are we gonna do is
he gets knocked down here we go and what
happens is he comes back and knocks him
out in the second round again shows you
the mental fortitude of Izzy that's why
he's the very very very best that we
have to offer
and so when you look at Strickland
and again if you're a Strickland fan
which I am do not get this confused if
you're a Strickland fan
what is your argument that he deserves
this title shot that's another fun
argument
it shows you this the state of the
middleweight division where it's at
Strickland's success also shows you the
state of the middleweight division where
it's at with his skill set when you look
at when you break this fight down
remember when khabib was fighting and we
knew he was he wanted to take them right
we knew he's gonna get the takedown and
because he is so dedicated to the deck
of stay in wrestling and obviously his
dad's his coach he's traded with
makachev they come up as kids they're
carrying goats up the hill and he
dedicated his entire life to this form
of wrestling well the advantage there is
let's say he's fighting a guy who has
American style wrestling or a guy that
doesn't have a wrestling background but
he somehow adapted to the wrestling in
the in MMA then he can stop the double
egg he can stop the single leg if you
have double unders he can navigate that
he's good against the cage the issue
with that is
unless you've been doing as long as as
khabib has
you might have let's say you have five
world-class takedowns or takedown
defenses the issue with that when you
find a guy like khabib he has 20. so
your five world-class takedown defenses
or takedowns if those don't work you are
s out of luck you are screwed you are
super screwed and it's not going to be
successful you have a long night in the
office well how that relates to Sean
Strickland
if you look at Sean Strickland's fights
and you break his fights down his path
to Victory
in in his Arsenal
there's not a ton of ways that he can
get this done now it's MMA so all this
being said it is MMA things can happen
things can happen
um not that I'm saying is he's going to
do this and he's never shown this in any
fight he's ever had but say shows up
like Luke Rockwell did when he was champ
against Bisping and you don't respect
the guy and at this level I don't care
who you are number ranked number 20
ranked number one undefeated coming off
two losses it doesn't matter if you
don't take the guy serious you're gonna
lose the fight it's just the way it goes
this level is just the way it goes so
can Strickland land a punch and and
knock out Izzy yeah
odds of them do it not freaking good so
if Izzy doesn't take this fight serious
we're only a much different fight is
he's never shown that in the past I
definitely don't expect them to do that
in this fight but back to Sean
Strickland in his Arsenal so what Sean
Street has left hooks good his jab can
be good his Philly shell of style
fighting which is a version of it but
remember in boxing you don't you have
less to worry about with the light kicks
uh the elbows the knees the takedowns so
he has a much more Square stance
it works and it doesn't it's worked for
Sean to a certain extent but when he
fights very high level Strikers that's
not gonna work it's just it's not gonna
work and we've seen it against act
appear it was just a matter of time but
we all thought going into that fight
that he was going to Grapple more it's
just not who Sean Strickland is that's
why we love him that's why I love him he
does bring it he brings he brings that
volume he brings that pace and he melts
guys like you do against Margaret Madoff
and that will work at a certain level
until you get to the upper echelon guys
especially with the Striking of Izzy the
Striking for Alex where they've seen it
all and you're one-dimensional you know
if Julia Strickland doesn't kick
not a knockout puncher so for 25 minutes
Sean Strickland has to apply his game
plan if you're his coach and you're
looking at what do we do well we bring
pressure we're tough we don't really
grapple we don't throw like kicks so you
have to hope that he can manage the
distance not get hit with a bomb from
Izzy and just keep Izzy on the on the
back of his heels and get him and just
aggressively hunt this guy down for 25
minutes probably win decision you're not
gonna k o it's not your thing he's a
decision fighter
and if you're as coaching staff you're
you're looking at us going it's gonna be
tough
Ken Sean Strickland with his Philly
shell style fighting and not a knockout
artist can that style that limited style
where it's a jab a good hook hopefully
the ride opens up no kicks no takedowns
Jiu Jitsu is not really our thing
um and is that level of styling that
limited style good enough not for Izzy
to figure out in 25 minutes and land a
bomb
the odds in history to say no
um
I think what is what is is he a plus 600
or my I'm sorry minus 600. he's a heavy
favorite minus 600 yeah
Izzy should probably be again this is no
disrespect this is very black and white
just analytical thinking
to me Izzy should probably be somewhere
in the ballpark of minus 2000.
damn
yeah a minus 600 is you know 100 plus
when you look at his chances of figuring
out Izzy who again if you like khabib's
grappling he has 20 world-class moves
that you've never seen you might be able
to stop the first five you might be able
to figure out the first three after that
it's just he's a Swiss army knife this
one this one that you gotta keep up for
25 minutes for Izzy it's that way and
striking
he's compete against much better
Strikers in glory coming up he's had
what 60 fights and he's figured those
guys out except for Alex at the time and
then MMA he's seen this style he's seen
a Apollo Casa style who again a lot of
pressure but a little more power than
Strickland right and he's navigated that
he's figured out that that kind of pace
he's he's seen it before
um
I I think minus 2000 is probably more
realistic
and this is different than
sugar Shawn and
and our boy aljo because
aljo had a significant advantage in the
the wrestling grappling department and
Suga had a significant advantage in the
Striking department and he took
advantage of that he realized watching
the last fight that okay when he rushes
in if you don't land that take down he
rushes in he leaves himself open we can
capitalize on that he did that
for Sean if you're looking at this fight
you're going what can we capitalize on
again the the Sean Strickland fan base
you know we can grapple when has he ever
done that if there was a time to do it
had been the Alex Pierre fight now
to that extent when I had him on food
truck I said you know that Ox fight what
happened I thought I thought you could
get it done we've never seen anybody
grapple Alex I thought you'd be the guy
he goes I was planning to and then I got
in there and I just did my thing next
you know I wake up on the canvas
okay so does he learn from that fight I
I don't Sean Strickland his experience I
don't know if you're gonna change that
mentality also he's been very successful
that mentality very successful with his
skill set very very successful
you know it's 27-5 dude so you go tell
that guy in the gym hey man I know all
you do is Spar but let's add in a
wrinkle let's add a distance let's add
this in maybe we should try this he's
going nah man I want 27 fights like this
out of 32. kick rocks nerd
and I don't think he's into it in the
biggest fight of his life
I just think there's levels to this game
and I think this shows where the
middleweight division is at and it's not
great but it also shows you how great it
is he is he's cleaned out the entire
Division and also from what I hear
around the UFC water cooler the UFC did
not want to give Sean Strickland this
title fight
Izzy's the one because remember
chailed when he was on The Show Goes
they want to do uh Sergey versus Jon
Jones in Australia they don't happen to
put up for Izzy they don't think they're
gonna be able to figure it out so
they're gonna they I think they commit
to five pay-per-views in Australia so
they need to land somebody big for him I
think and he said Steve is not gonna be
ready to go obviously he's a little
wrong on that the day later Steve Avers
John got announced whatever you got bad
info but at the time that was the UFC's
plans until stipei signed the contract
it was going to be John versarge in
Australia give him a big fight
but is he wet hold on that went away
right
from what I hear Izzy and his team is he
particularly called Dana was like give
me Sean Strickland I'll get rid of this
guy I will starch this guy
then they because they didn't want to
give him the title shot remember we've
heard but you know it's the passport
issue and all this I heard it was the
kind of the reservations from the UFC
going um we don't want this guy in the
message and the stuff that he does also
just from uh entertainment standpoint he
has so many decisions he's a decision
he's a volume decision fighter he's not
a finisher so they don't want that as
their their champion and then sponsors
there's a variety of reasons the UFC
brass doesn't want him as the as the guy
I think that's also why we enjoy him we
know and that's why you know we we root
for Sean Strickland we know he's the guy
who says F the man says things he
shouldn't say
um says off the cuff stuff there's a lot
of people that can relate to that
there's a ton of people because how many
people in the world look at Izzy just
worldwide but or you could say in North
America how many people look at is he go
man you look at him well I could do that
not a lot that's like looking at LeBron
going yeah I could do that these guys
are freaks now if you look at Sean how
many people look at that and go was that
the fastest runner
didn't that hit the hardest
he's not the quickest he's not the
strongest there's a lot a lot of people
mass mass people that can relate to Sean
Strickland than they are Izzy they go
man that guy gives me hope
you look up his upbringing Covina you
know and we'll I'll be in Covina this
Friday with Brian Cowell no shows
everyone sold out I think there's three
tickets left across the board for both
shows Friday you have one show at seven
I think that shows at 9 30 that's Friday
at the Lafayette in Covina me and Brian
headline together for the first time in
a hot second you have to go that chin I
covered it Bud all right just making
sure thank you sir
um so I think a lot of people that's one
of the reasons Sean's uh you know so
light
you know he has no filter a lot of
people can relate to him more people can
relate to him than they can Izzy or a
sugar Shawn or Jon Jones you look at him
and go what's his skill set
works his ass off great cardio tough as
Nails doesn't quit heart of a champion
tough is all get out
I like that guy yeah and to your point
they didn't watch Sean Strickland drica
Scott hurt so correct I had to go with
him so yeah the policies got hurt yeah
that's what they wanted they wanted to
do policies fighting that didn't uh end
up he got hurt so Sean Strickland was
the next guy up
again the argument for him earning a
style shot beating two on-ranked guys
it's a tough sell I I think
also I think too there's not a lot of
hype around this now when they do the
press conferences they could add some
more color to it they could add some
more intriguing buys to it and I think
UFC's banking on that but you don't see
a lot of talk for a pay-per-view around
this
at all
the breakdown is to get done and you'll
see knows that there's a kind of a late
card they put together so you have taito
vasek went off two losses volkov
um
you know Justin tafa Austin Lane that
would not be on a paper you on any other
uh pay-per-view you know you have fan
favorite Tyson Pedro my boy Jamie
Malarkey could have been on the main car
but whatever Carlos oldberg's a fun one
Jack Jenkins yeah it's a tough card
it's a tough guard
alrighty
do we have any questions in the comments
did anybody say that how they see uh
Strickland getting this done did Georgie
say anything
he's got questions for you but uh you
want to say that for later
yeah we can save for the end okay
um actually
how about we do a little bit of a
DraftKings
oh can you believe let's take a little
break here by break I mean live read can
you believe we've had seven months
without NFL game thank God college
football start this past weekend and
hopefully y'all made money on my Buffs
who were a plus 20 Underdog are you
kidding me hope you guys made money also
the best bet would have been before they
beat the breaks off TCU because they
were the over under was three games do
you still think it's three games now
it's gone up to five people got three
you would have a lock whatever uh well
the good thing is the NFL is here and
draftking Sportsbook an official sports
betting partner the NFL is giving you a
can't miss offer for week one this week
new customers can get 200 in bonus bets
instantly when you bet just five bucks
on any NFL game DraftKings is hooking
everyone up with a game day greatness
all customers can take advantage of two
new offers every single game day this
September check the app to see what to
get download right now use the code shop
show schab show to sign up new customers
can take home two hundred dollars in
bonus bets instantly instantly just for
betting five bucks that's coach shop
show only on draftking Sportsbook an
official sports betting partner of the
NFL the crown is yours I need to read
that don't worry gambling problem call
1-800 Gambler visit
www.1800 gambler.net in New York call
8778 Hope and why or text Hope NY
467-369 in Connecticut help is available
for problem gambling call
888-789-77 or visit
ccpg.org please play responsibly on
behalf of Boot Hill Casino and Resort
Kansas 21 plus age varies by
jurisdiction void in Ontario
cdkng.co football for eligibility terms
and responsible gaming resources bonus
bets expire seven days after issuance
eligibility and deposit restrictions
apply if you're still with me it's
DraftKings promo code shop show that on
my Buffs to beat the
piss out of Nebraska
yes sir oh I tell you what man I'm also
happy to welcome these uh some of my
favorite undies man I take pride and
undies and I wear the old school undies
like my Dad wears I got people stay in
the front sometime and I don't like
white undies I like them dark colored
for a variety of reasons am I right guys
and this is uh brought to you by sheath
boxer briefs that's right uh every time
you hear my voice or if you were able to
see my face it would be obvious that I'm
wearing a pair of sheath sheath boxer
briefs they're stretchy Fabrics made of
a moisture wicking technology that makes
them super soft so when I'm stressed I'm
about a fight I'm stressing about
football watching I got bets on the line
your boy's sweating but I feel good
cause she is there all right
particularly it's for staying cool after
trying sheath you can never go back to
those old tired brands that your pops
used to wear all right I love the Dual
pouches that keep your man Parts talking
about your wiener separated all right
it's a game changer sheath uses
materials like bamboo and mash for even
more cool and comfort all right it's the
most comfortable underwear you will put
on your trunk all right
she's also has bamboo shirts hoodies all
designed for maximum Comfort all right
so if that's something you're interested
in go to sheathunderwear.com right now
use the code promo code shop to receive
20 off today that sheath underwear
s-h-e-a-t-h-underwear.com today and use
promo code Schaub for 20 off
now let's get back to the program
all right here's a picture of rose Namba
Junior's pinky that Ariel helwani posted
it looks a lot worse than I that I
thought
yeah and she couldn't close her hand
well she couldn't close that pinky for
sure but yeah yeah I mean it just it
hurts you know it's like sticking out
this can be tough to be tough to throw
that yeah and there was a right hand too
the money maker Daddy
um that's a bummer yeah her hand looks
like schmiegel's there
let's be on the whole hand doesn't look
good I don't know what the deal is with
the other ones with the whole entire
hand when you're fine it's tough to have
pretty hands man that pinky is atrocious
yeah like broke inward huh it's like
going in and out that's not bad injury
though it's not horrible I mean
definitely affect her throwing
especially the right hand which is a
bummer but uh pinky broken or not she
wasn't winning that fight
yeah and some people some fans were
noticing that Trevor Whitman wasn't
there uh with Trevor was there oh no he
wasn't apparently are you sure yeah yeah
I thought I saw him at the start no I
mean everyone's saying that they didn't
see him there maybe because it's in
Paris
like check please I think someone
mentioned on the broadcast that she kind
of went to a different camp for this one
and I'm wondering why maybe because you
know listen coming off a loss yeah you
know
oh yeah
that was interesting yeah that's a
bummer she had Pat in her Corner yeah
and then people were giving him a hard
time too this is just fans by the way
it's not like actual the commentators
actually thought Pat did a great job
saying like forget about the pinky you
know just focus on the fight you don't
need your pinky right now yeah but
people online are giving him crap like
that's messed up to say you know that's
his girl what should he say though no
I'm with it they wanted to be like okay
but are you okay oh my God should we get
out of here coach
oh my God your pink is broke what are we
gonna do we have dinner tomorrow night
in Eiffel Tower
how are we gonna eat croissants
people like Pat's an [__] man you
believe he
forces I was like come on that's lame
this guy says or this person says Pat
bear can use you continues to be a
garbage ass coach
it's like no
let me know can we play that
we'll get us kicked off oh yeah we
should not do it
I'm sure all he says was
who cares about your pinky if you don't
need it right now something like that
they're not girlfriend boyfriend in that
fight it's coach and fighter yeah
he's like oh Babe oh you're like so bad
at the
what award the fighters only Awards with
that finger like that we should just get
out of here for it gets worse
I know if you win you get a title shot
but let's get out of here
people look for any reason to hate yeah
especially on Pat and Rose whatever
people are stupid so uh Rampage Jackson
he talked about it on on your show that
he was gonna his one fight that he wants
to come back with is the guy Sarah
schoonover and I didn't like it I want
to be very clear I told him and my boy
Harrison who owns UF UFL I said titties
he hasn't fought Daryl schoonover we got
a quick Club titties man I know Daryl
schoonover but I mean that's how people
know him so we just say it this one time
and that's yeah I guess so Quinn was
like oh I'm gonna come back if I would
love to fight titties hey don't call
them titties B titties is like he's like
a construction guy he hasn't worked five
in like eight years
now for those of you that don't know
if you're new to MMA if you or maybe you
just even if you're five years into the
MMA scene
Daryl schoonover was he was he was on
Rampages no he was on my team uh coached
by Rashad Evans on The Ultimate Fighter
season 10. Rampage and Daryl schoonover
hated each other Rampage gave him the
nickname titties which some would say is
a form of bullying and they come they
got it to it they're supposed to fight
on the show like they were gonna fight
backstage they did not like each other
and Rampage doesn't letting this go and
apparently uh schoonover's down let's
see Jackson broke the news on the
Jackson podcast while talking with
former UC middleweight champion rockhold
the front of UFL wanted me to fight I
was like okay I'll come back and fight
uh Grudge matches only so I'm going to
fight titties from Ultimate Fighter just
signed the contract yesterday or today
for December y'all be in shape by that
time I'll be 2 30 hopefully I'll fight
titties
schoonover what's he been doing scroll
down I just went to his uh his topology
he hasn't fought since like 2015. and he
lost
and what's he doing these days
I don't know was he like driving for
Uber and he's like you want me to do
what
I'll type in today it's going to be all
that Rampage stuff
go to his uh Twitter's Twitter right
there get out
dear the boss
joined in 2013.
the last post I see is 2016.
yeah no idea
I I mean yeah I I don't get the upside
for Rampage on this but you know I'll
support my boy
it's in December it's December he said
he signed it for December is it in Mesa
Arizona
wait so is your head trainer deal scoot
over so maybe he's training
oh he is good for him man there with the
kiddo
that's cute oh wait this is freaking
2014. holy [__] that's 489 weeks ago
Chad I know we can't get much on this
guy
okay well hopefully he's doing well and
uh that's some money for him yeah I hope
they're paid him decently
uh okay so this is Henry sahuto talking
about the pay-per-view buys that uh Sean
O'Malley and algeman Sterling did for
UFC 292 and just before you say this if
if um the Twitter Community or the X
Community
um
so who knows off on this okay so I mean
I don't believe let's see who this is in
the first place he said he heard from
one of his friends at ESPN yeah ESPN's
not really okay so he said it was
anywhere between three guess what guys I
have friends at ESPN if I can say who
but sugar Shawn did anywhere between 300
350 000 pay-per-view buys that's it
that's all Sean O'Malley made in
pay-per-view buys is 350 pay-per-view
buys is that a surplus or is that down
the other guy who will probably more
than like you know is Al Jermaine
Sterling uh I think aljo intro came out
and said so this is what sugar said
Henry's saying saying Me and Al Joe only
did 350 uh paper 350 000 paper he buys
according to his girlfriend's Source I
just talked to UFC I heard it's upwards
of 570 000 legit no kizzy I don't know
the young terms there's kizzy and I'm
not a kidding is that like a Glizzy I'm
guessing not kidding no cap
yeah no tap such a weird word
where's that come from
38 I'm 40. no yes I can't say no why why
no how do you put on your hat and people
put like caps you know for this like you
can happen right now for lying it's
triggering for me
the phrase read it from
I mean the 1900s
uh mean to brag or exaggerate your lie
about something
no capping you described something that
has no limit well yeah that I mean
that's the white person
no cap on this stock fund
No Cap means dang it's a back so it
spread the other aspects of African
American culture before adopted by
mainstream culture I see a little white
nerdy kids using that all the time it
messes me up because every time I see
people use it they use the emoji of an
actual cat yes I'm like it has to be
doing okay
too old dude
okay
um oh on your season of The Ultimate
Fighter
apparently Kurt Angle was offered five
hundred thousand dollars to join us holy
[__] that would have been a nightmare
for me
Kurt Angle and Kimbo yeah
I mean it's bad enough to put Roy Nelson
on there who had 30 previous fights I
had three mavichron had none he lied he
has I think one amateur fight well did
we we were kids you put Kurt Angle on
there a decorated National freaking
world-class world-class though yeah yeah
and at that level like you know Mark
Madison who was a I think a a
I think he either wasn't a national
champion but either way if you have that
wrestling background at that experience
level you dominate he had a lot of
injuries too though so at that point in
life I'm 41 years old I broke my neck
five times I sat back and realized I
started train for a little bit and
realized I'm past my Prime I can't do it
so I turn it down
he's also unable to pass the medical he
wouldn't beat Roy he wouldn't beat Roy
but the rest of us we would have had our
hands full he he's such a good wrestler
at that level I mean we're like wait
what and check out what they've
in 96 when the UFC came out so the first
time was right after Olympics 96 then
what was was involved with the UFC back
then the kidney and they gave me the
best contract it wasn't very good
contract it was 10 fights for 150 000
wow that's fifteen thousand per fight
and that was the highest they were gonna
give the fighters for the fights that's
back in the day yeah market value Daddy
that's been a nightmare Kurt Angle on
The Ultimate Fighter with us you should
have Roy Nelson Kurt Angle we're like
what is happening
it would have been I mean it's already
the biggest season right still oh it's
the fighters so that would have been
crazier yeah that'd been massive
all right uh Jorge Mazda doll he was
speaking with Mark raymondy at ESPN
saying that if he were to do to come
back he should defend his uh he should
gaichi should defend his BMF belt
against Mosby dog at 55 I don't know
what weight yeah if it's at 55 and Corey
can make 55 again I'd watch that all
freaking day and the division could use
it I can lie to you both both poor a and
just in case you could use the likes of
amazfood all net oh he says 170 here
well well then the UFC and I can do that
although
the BMF title it's not like other titles
where it's going to hold up the division
I dig it
all right I dig that miles at all get
you at 70 if he comes back yeah
you already know this but Sergey
pavlovich is the backup for Joan Stipe
which is pretty cool
I like I like this post by dosimpore
they said uh are you gonna be a backup
Fighter for some you know some big fight
he goes I'm not I'm not a backup fighter
that's not what I do
I like that yeah I mean he's super
successful now too right so he didn't
have to do anything I'm not that's not
what I do yeah
uh real quick back on Sean O'Malley he
posted this about managers
there are managers that take 20 20 of
the fighter purses and 20 some of their
bonuses if you do this to the fighters
you are a piece of
have you ever experienced anything like
that yeah that's standard usually it's
the managers are 20s High usually it's
10 percent and but then also your
coaches are 10 too
and then the way it worked at Grudge
with Trevor Whitman is 10 if you got
like a knockout bonus or something you
get 10 which it's a lot of money man
especially back then it's a lot a lot of
money when you're giving out you know
you expect that bonus and you're you're
giving up a good amount of it right away
it's a tough pill to swallow
oh
um speaking of that Stephen Thompson
even to this day he says that he wasn't
paid even like his Camp fees and he did
that I think he extended his Camp
because when it was something happened
to his first opponent yeah Dana said
he's gonna take care of his campus he
said they will work something out but
yeah I bet his next fight does just add
more money into it I would assume I
would hope
well that sucks
all right so this was in the news quite
a bit uh it's just Dana White getting
upset and Rob and Al Jermaine Sterling
he kind of went off of them
because you know they don't obviously
they don't want to fight each other for
the time but everybody in this room
everybody that watches this video knows
how I feel about this crap white said
it's last night's Contender series
content series by far better an ultimate
fighter not even close at this point
yeah I hate it and if that's why you did
uh why did you even get in the sport if
that's your mentality in the way that
you think I don't even want the title I
don't want the championship we're
friends we're this we're that this is
not you could be friends with everybody
in the business there's a lot of nice
people in the business a lot of good
people it's not about friendship it's
about finding out who's the best in the
world and if you don't want to find out
who the best in the world is this is not
the place for you should be somewhere
else there's plenty of places to fight
where they don't give a crap what you do
doesn't work here I'm with Dana and this
is marab's I think manager
I agree let's find out who's the best in
the world is I can tell you at eight
number six Cheeto Vera maraba is 100
ready for a title fight in December aljo
is ready neither will be salty if the
other gets it let's see if it plays out
true to Sport and find out who's the
best
um it's too late
it's too late because
with the UFC's looking at us they know
the relationship between Moab and aljo
let's say marab wins good chance he you
know he's very talented dude let's say
he was beat sugar Sean aljo wins one
against whoever
then we're back at square one they won't
fight each other
it would I think they would be more
willing to do this if aljo committed
going up weight classes fighting the
alcohol but he lost right and he wants
the rematch with yeah so the UFC's like
no no because if you become Champion
then you hold the cards there's no way
this relationship hopefully Fighters
learn from this I get you don't fight
your brother and stuff like that me and
Jay and Karma were super close super
close we had an agreement we will not
fight each other for any amount of money
unless for the title fight kiss world
it's life-changing we both agreed if we
both get the title shot we will rip each
other's heads off prior to that no I'm
with Rob and alja on that hey we're
teammates we shouldn't have to fight
before one becomes a title Contender or
gets the title shot but once you get
there that stuff goes out the window
because I know you know you've had
friends in your life we're like man
we're gonna be friends forever we're
gonna talk let's get matching tattoos
you know we're Blood Brothers let's cut
each other and rub our wrists together
and share the blood like some psychos
we're never not gonna be friends and
then life happens and they say you know
like man I've talked to insert name in
years
because right now you guys have the same
goal you're on the same team fast
forward five years from now when aljo
starts a family a chance that you're not
gonna talk to marab man you're gonna
wish you guys fight each other
so I I I like the how they have each
other's backs and that's rare in this
game but it never works out for anybody
it doesn't work out from Rob now he's
transmitting me a title shot he's
probably gonna have to win two more be
undeniable in the UFC's like fine here
they're just gonna make it the toughest
toughest path possible for him to become
Champion now
or if you would just kept quiet you know
just kept quiet about it behind the
scenes him and aljo trying to figure out
all right you call it this guy so we
don't have to fight dude behind the
scenes don't come out and be like we're
brothers
the UFC's like cool your brothers who
are never going to fight for a title
they never reward this ever no he hates
it he always hates it we all do
I mean it's Gotta sucked to fight your
freaking I mean the guy that helps you
get to the point
yeah but I hear you that's business
that's the business I'm trying to think
back to all my friends that I grew up
with too I don't really
how many talk to small Pickens now I'm
small yeah you just grew up you're
you're you don't have the same goals you
don't have you have the same belief
system you're into different things yeah
if you ran into them they're your boy
but if it comes to your rent or your boy
we're talking about
um
all right I thought this was interesting
Jon Jones uh he basically said that when
he was in the fight with Dominic Reyes
he really felt at that moment that that
was his match like he had a good career
but that's the that's the point he's
going to be like Kudos Dominic Reyes man
yeah he must read this back girl that's
cool he's falling on tough times yes
he's fallen on the toughest time since
that fight but at least he knows even
John was like damn yeah
uh this is too long to read but that's
basically the gist of it and that's from
the overdogs podcast
uh say this is Jesse Owens quote you put
I decided I wasn't going to come down I
was I was going to fly I was going to
stay up in there forever
um I was fighting Dominic Reyes it was
round one he hit me with a spinning back
kick to the face and then he punched me
in the stomach and I hit the floor it
was technically a knock down even though
look they had in his eyes and the way he
talked to me before the fight tell me he
was a multi-sport athlete he was afraid
of me and he believed it was his Destiny
beat me all this type of stuff I'm in
the fight with him he was giving me a
true effing run for my money he was the
only person to do it outside of
Alexander guestfin agree I remember
seeing myself F you may have met your
match John
damn he said hey you've had a great
career you've done a lot of great things
this kid he wanted he's hungry for it
John 2K if you come up short on this one
just don't let don't let him knock you
out but you can just kind of skate
through this one let the kid have it wow
a lot of people still think Donald
Gray's won that fight I mean come on
it's kind of validates Don Reyes though
he's probably like hopefully this gives
him some fire man he was so good
well balls for John and for being so
he's so humble these days it's kind of
cool man bro different or about him when
I ran to him
completely different dude
hopefully him and
and uh DC will become like homies which
seems like it's heading during the
heading towards that direction yeah baby
um all right so Paul Felder he got
inspired from Korean zombie
and then he's saying like damn it maybe
he wants to do it one more time and then
he even entered the usada pool oh good
for him just in case yeah that'd be cool
I think everyone who's ever fought in
there we saw the Korean zombie you know
zombie yeah here's the thing though
the crowd ain't singing that song for
you you know like I don't think that
might be the best send-off ever I don't
think we're ever gonna see that again oh
it was incredible but they're doing a
way better job of the send-off season
like lately they are but that zombie one
they couldn't even
doctor that like that thing was so
organic and beautiful beautiful and we
should cherish the moment for sure yeah
tell you what if I'm zombie I'm selling
shirts off that and listen a little
while ago I had this idea man that
zombie should start selling shirts but
he doesn't have an idea where to get
started that's cool that's why he needs
to find Shopify if you could trade a
benchwarmer for a goat you'd do it right
get your business a game changing pick
up by choosing the Commerce platform
with the internet's best converting
check out that's Shopify
Shopify is the Commerce platform
revolutionizing millions of businesses
worldwide all right whether you're a
garage entrepreneur or IPO ready Shopify
is the only tool you need to start run
and grow your business without the
struggle all right we got you guys man
Shopify Powers 10 of all e-commerce in
the US and shopify's truly Global Force
powering all birds rothies and Brooklyn
and millions of other entrepreneurs of
every size across 170 countries wow plus
shopify's award-winning help is there to
support you all the way to the Top This
Is Possible powered by Shopify sign up
for just one dollar per month trial
period at shopify.com
schab all lower case again that's
lowercase shopify.com
shop all lower case all you gotta do is
go to shopify.com shop to take your
business to the next level today today
shopify.com
you want another
oh we are just in the given mood on this
Labor Day because every show you see me
do especially live your boys all up on
that happy hippo I got my K dips this is
Kratom dips the first to Market ever K
dips with a Wintergreen Razzle Dazzle
they got powders they got gummies they
got it all I use the high concentrated
uh shots as well they have them sour
apple butterscotch is okay not my fave
sour Apple's my fave right and right now
when you go to happyhippo.com promo code
thick with three C's 23 you get 20 for
life for the best Kratom on the planet
that's Happy Hippos the wild west out
there you know who to trust you know if
you love it you know if you just want to
try it save 20 off you can share it with
your grandma your mom your aunt your
buddy your Uber driver Postmates whoever
it is go to happyhippo.com promo code
thick23 for 20 off the best Kratom on
the market the only Kratom that I trust
that's Happy Hippo happy hip dot com
promo code thick 23 20 off
what do you got Jen alrighty um how
about we go to some questions real quick
because this is perfect timing
uh this is from these are questions from
the from the live chat from the live
chatty chat Georgie has uh giving us
okay Georgie what do you got buddy these
are picked by Georgie we don't know what
these are fire away all right Rick
Fernandez is asking what does Brandon
think of the recent running photos of
Nick Diaz and Derek Lewis and I have
them right here
they're just running together yeah but
they're both looking in shape and Nick
is
every now and then Nick does look pretty
ripped like right there yeah they both
look good yeah
uh I mean for black beast he's he's
really gotten down man he's taking his
condition another level which is good
for him he looked phenomenal just he
resigned with UFC so there's a
Resurgence there he's trying to take it
more serious because he was kind of on
The Cutting Board there uh for Nick Diaz
I think he is getting in shape for a
comeback against a Jake Paul or Logan
Paul
also the easiest fight from as far as
him jumping back into the the UFC tough
task for him but those those big Marquee
fights that you make a ton of money ton
of exposure I see Jake Paul Nick Diaz
next
alrighty and this is from yts who won
Francis or UFC and this is based off of
this new purchase from the Saudi what's
it called srj
Saudi Arabia's public investment fund uh
so they bought like 100 million dollar
stake in pfl Saturday was slowly taking
over all major sports I don't know if
you see this clearly you see it in the
in soccer or soon as football if you're
watching scratch the pond uh they're
doing soccer right they're doing golf
yeah right so so with all that stuff
they're slowly infiltrating taking over
everyone if you've also noticed they've
started kind of poking at the NBA 2 to
get their big games over there as well
I'm sure that's just a matter of time he
said that also this acquisition dropped
Endeavor stock by 2 billion
this acquisition interesting so his his
question is who won yeah meaning Francis
or the UFC
everybody's winning the the UFC is
Untouchable so even though they're
stocked lowered they're going to be fine
uh for pfl this is good and hopefully
that 100 million allows them to sign
more guys
um their issue is Stars it's impossible
to make stars especially homegrown
organic Stars if their business model is
similar to Bellator where you can get
the leftovers of DFC and pay these guys
all these money and do these one-time
fights you know like uh you know like
the horse Gracies can Shamrocks these
one-offs that's no way to run a business
so hopefully that 100 million allows
them to invest in you know some young
guys and build actual Stars which take
years to to you know come to fruition
there so
as far as who won you know Francis won
the UFC's winning no matter what take
them out of it the pfl is still up for
debate even though they have 100 million
dollars do they know what to do with it
what are they gonna do with 100 million
Francis won more so than the UFC and pfl
he the he left he got this insane
contract from pfl where he's fighting
much easier competition when it comes to
mixed martial arts and he's also going
to make all the bag when he fights Dyson
Fury Win Lose or Draw and then he gets
to come to pfl and fight lesser
competition he's the face of the
organization Francis won in this whole
thing
for pfl it's up in the air we'll see
because right now with their current
roster it's not even comparable to the
UFC you don't want Championship to
Bellator it's not even close
so they have to invest in the in
bringing up their own talent and getting
the the divisions as
competitive as it is in the UFC or one
Championship that takes years so we'll
see yeah
all right next one is from Eric Wojo uh
what do you think of Holland versus Ian
Gary Kevin Hall and Gary love that fight
absolutely love that fight love that
fight like I said for for Ian Gary I
would
you know there's a few fights
um again for the UFC they're gonna have
to we're gonna see how how much of a
belief they have in Ian Gary because he
does have a rock ship on his back and he
has that you know the Dublin support
um so we're gonna see usually the UFC
they've gotten smart with you know they
learn the lesson with guys like Darren
till who didn't work out for them or
they learned their lesson with sage
Northcutt with Ian Gary you have this
massive massive potential Superstar how
fast you want him to get there and is he
ready by all accounts he looks ready so
I assume he's going to get I think he's
gonna jump over Kevin Holland I think
he's getting a big name next I think
they think this kid is ready and I agree
with them
so I don't think we see Kevin Hall
unless Kevin wins his next fight and he
gets in that top you know eight
discussion I think in Gary's head for
Sizzler
all right this one's kind of a comment
more but uh so Jay underscore CX c-e-ex
uh Izzy says he wants to sub Strickland
Izzy's defense might open up some holes
if he's looking to go to ground or
scrambles up and down
so he did say he wants to sell them I
know he said he wants to sub him which
is uh is he playing you know the mind
game here thinking
that Strickland's gonna grapple more so
he's like hopefully Strickland does grab
what opens up for me to submit him just
to put that doubt in Strickland's head
because
Strickland coaches know is these teams
know everybody watching show knows
everybody in this room knows hopefully
if you don't you probably should be
working here is Izzy's biggest liability
is his grappling as far as we know now
you're predicating that off the yawn
fight which I don't think we learned
much from there he's massive so I think
Strickland
if his game plan is to Grapple and shoot
more he's gonna realize that it's easier
said than done
now this being said there is there is
one thing here that we need to be privy
of we need to be careful of there and
again
Izzy has done this in the past I don't
think he's doing this fight because he
told Dana he will take out Strickland so
I don't see him doing this but there is
a case where it goes to decision it's
Izzy on his back foot and he can't land
that knockout blow to Sean because he's
so damn tough and you do get a bit of a
boring fight there's a slight chance of
that I don't think so I think Izzy's a
game time dude I think he's missed a
Showtime he's gonna perform a put on a
show especially in his backyard out
there in Australia I know New Zealand
but I think in Australia he's gonna put
on for those fans but there's a slight
chance that this could be a boring fight
and Izzy plays it safe I I don't think
he's gonna do that but that is a
possibility hmm
yeah I don't know I thought it'd be a
great fight because Sean always
goes forward right and Izzy that's like
but Izzy stays on his back foot yeah
maybe just pep moving moving he's
banking the rounds banking rounds like
all right here it comes in Strickland's
defense it's just awkward and Izzy can't
really find it again I don't think it's
gonna happen at all I think we're gonna
get a high reel KO highlight real KO but
I there there's a chance there where
Strickland surprises us and the kicks
and the punch in the elbows whatever is
he has kind of an off night again we
haven't seen this but if he has an off
night it's gonna be tough to put away
Strickland he is toughest nails and you
get just this
kind of lackluster performance and Izzy
wins by decision
again don't think it's going to happen
just saying it could it's a possibility
yes
so check this out our boy Ben Davis he's
actually going to be doing a fight with
one of Anderson Silva's Sons Gabriel
Silva they're both kind of like early on
in their I'm gonna show you Ben's
topology real quick
he's had a submission match where he we
lost in like 30 seconds got starched
um and then Gabriel Silvis want to know
he wants to know what amateur oh he has
amateur too but a pro he won
so Ben's gonna box him
Ben just wants to do this stuff huh he's
down to do it which I gotta give him
credit man and he's fighting Anderson
you know good Leading Edge there he's
fighting his son
um
I mean I like that Ben has the
turtleneck on in the fight promo here I
don't like that topology he's wearing a
black shirt how do you not have your
fight in apology in a black turtleneck I
mean you guys know we're rooting for Ben
here yeah does Ben also have a wrist
brace on there I think it's a gloves oh
there no they look like it's definitely
not a glove it's either wrist wraps or
he has a uh he broke his wrist
yeah he's all I don't it's like a
younger picture of Ben
we love Ben here we do when is that
fight it is going to be September 23rd
in Newcastle England damn and you gotta
go over to England then hopefully
they're paying for all this dog of
course they have to be
well you'd be surprised
well there you go run for bang get it
done dog
what's been strength
his mind
is a Sean Strickland mindset he's he's I
think he's he's a hard worker so that's
hard worker for sure hard worker hard
worker he's got a [__] relief for
that he's got a lot of belief in himself
and he has the power of a black
turtleneck
definitely beat him up on the mic there
yeah
is that it that's it man um just the
fights nice man oh wait there's also a
fight coming up I think there was
oh it's the Jorge Mosby doll it's gonna
be ver doom and uh dos Santos that's
coming up on Friday yeah oh sick yeah
what time is that fight God damn y'all
being Covina doing shows not that that's
bad but I really wanted to watch this
fight since 8 PM Eastern so five
yeah five but uh they probably won't
walk to eight no we'll have it on in the
back you gonna come to the show chin
yeah I'll be there for the first one
though okay yeah
wow
I mean I don't know how you call it I'm
probably leaning towards verdum they're
both on that Saucy sauce I can't wait
dish both jacked as hell right is it
weird to say it's the best fight of the
weekend
that thing is dope dude both freaking
wild west on supplements to the greatest
Brazilians to ever do it JDS looking
jacked Purdue Jack City all the acai in
the world
Simon and bare knuckle MMA I know dude
take my freaking money Jorge
uh see that Friday night you got a nice
little weekend yeah that Friday night
you got Saturday night a few beatdowns
going on you got Izzy Sean Strickland
you also got CU Nebraska all right get
some beat downs going down there uh they
got a decent card uh fan favorite tied
to avasa who we've done chewies with
here volkanov
just in topost and Lane you know I'm
rooting for my former uh football Buddy
there uh that's gonna be a tough one for
him Tyson Pedro who's a fan favorite as
well and one of our favorites
um again not a great card I'm looking
forward to the prelims with Carl's
ulberg and JB Malarkey outside that it
is what it is but Izzy Sean Strickland's
going down this Saturday 7 P.M Pacific 9
p.m central time and again we are doing
a live JRE fight companion with Brian
Cowan Sam tripley myself and Mr Joseph
Rogan that's on JRE YouTube then goes up
uh on Spotify and that is Saturday at 9
00 PM Central Time Live on YouTube
um Covina is this Friday again 30
tickets left total for both shows the
thing will sell out it's Monday so
um that's September 8th and September
21st through the 23rd I'm in Spokane
Washington spoke and comedy club with my
face that's September 21st through the
23rd that's a Thursday Friday Saturday I
mean skank Fest Vegas September 29th uh
since through October 1st I won't be
there on Sunday right I gotta get home
on Sundays but I will be there that
Friday and Saturday and then I'm in Iowa
October 13th and 14th one show Friday
one show Saturday Niagara Falls that's
Casino play so I need fans to come out
otherwise it's a weird Room Niagara
Falls New York that's a casino November
4th and 5th one show Friday one show
Saturday and I'm in Chicago December 8th
through the 9th that's two shows Friday
two shows Saturday but Covina you're up
this Friday with me and Brian Cowan then
Spokane is September 21st to the 23rd
get your tickets at thickboy.com is that
it Jen that's it all right kids love you
thanks for watching another live one in
the books hope you guys dig it and uh be
nice each other I'll see you out there
on the streets till next time I'm out